there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
september to test for ourselves i did it
i got my hands on clinique black honey
never did i imagine a lipstick my mom
wore back in the day would go viral in
2021 but here we are this is a sheer
lipstick lip gloss hybrid that has this
just bitten pink tint to it it
supposedly looks great on everyone
because it blends with your natural lip
tone i really love this i feel like you
can get the same effect with one of
those burt's bees tinted chapsticks at
the drugstore that are like five dollars
but the color of this is super beautiful
and the formula is so comfortable on the
lips it's hydrating and has a nice slip
to it about face is halsey's makeup
brand it just dropped these two new
products the fractal glitter eye paint
and the fractal glitter brow gel let's
talk about the eye paint first i thought
this packaging was very cool and new
like something i haven't seen before i
don't know it seemed fun and i love the
color options with these eye paints it
was a good mix of neutrals and more
exciting colors i was worried these
would dry quickly but i actually had no
trouble applying and blending them out
they didn't get streaky or patchy but i
will say the bolder colors like this
blue one do need a second layer for full
coverage if you're a one and done
eyeshadow kind of person i think you'll
like these
now let's talk about the glitter brow
gels listen i'm not gonna pretend that
i'm interested in glitter brows but the
products seem fun and i am interested in
fun i'm actually obsessed with the brush
on this i really like how the bristles
brushed my brows however it does deposit
a bit too much product you can see where
i kind of went outside the lines the
actual glitter effect is cute if you're
into that sort of thing i rubbed my
brows to see what the transfer situation
is like and surprisingly the hair seemed
to stay put and barely any glitter came
off so i think the gel part of this
product works really well i do think
that both of these products are really
overpriced for what they are but overall
i'm into this brand and i'm actually
really excited to see what they come out
with next i feel like it's been forever
since we as a group have been excited
over a sponge and this one has been
getting amazing reviews this is the real
techniques miracle air blend sponge i
tried this wet and dry it doesn't expand
very much when you wet it but i liked it
both ways i've never felt a sponge like
this before it's completely weightless
and squishy and because it's so squishy
you can actually really get into all
those crevices of your face i really
love how my makeup looked after using
this it just looked really seamlessly
blended i actually prefer this one way
more than the real techniques original
orange sponge the nano blur instant skin
blur and cream was an experience i think
i saw a tick tock that said they use
this on a set of euphoria to get rid of
shininess
so it says you can use it underneath
makeup and on top of makeup that hasn't
been set with powder yet so i tried it
both ways it definitely mattifies but it
leaves like a white powdery cast behind
i'm not sure if i put too much on or
what my makeup started bunching up
between my brows when i was blending my
foundation on top of it and it just
looked bad then i tried blending in a
small amount on my forehead because i
had some shine there and i feel like it
did a little something but not enough
for me to ever use this again i just
think it's too matte on my bare skin and
pretty underwhelming on top of makeup so
yeah i don't like this this is the
weirdest primer i've ever used this is
the smith cult untouched skin
brightening foaming face primer i
definitely over did it on my first
application it wasn't blending in at all
so i had to reapply it the foam actually
feels really nice on the skin and i
swear it has like this cooling sensation
that i really liked it felt good it's
like a nice first step to your makeup it
certainly does brighten i looked like a
victorian ghost woman i feel like this
almost lightened my foundation i get
that it's brightening but i didn't think
it would make my foundation a shade
lighter i had to mix in a deeper shade i
do think my makeup looked nice on top of
this primer but i'm just not into the
brightening aspect of it
[Music]
you